when you buy bitcoin what you are doing
is you are hiring millions of people
around the world and the strongest
computer network in the world to protect
your purchasing power and in an analog
economy that may not be valuable but in
a digital economy it's the single most
valuable thing that can protect your
purchasing power because the opportunity
costs in a digital economy in a digital
economy you don't have the opportunity
to buy physical real estate you can't
use gold on the computer so first of all
you there's gold in computers number one
again again
again the reason they work of course but
but hold on but when you look if i'm
gonna operate a 100 digital i'm going to
operate 100 digital in a digital economy
you cannot buy the analog
assets first of all when i say something
the strongest computer network in the
world to protect your purchasing first
of all when you're buying bitcoin you're
not you're not hiring somebody to
protect your purchasing power you're
just buying into a mass you know
delusion and you're just hoping that
bitcoin miners the bitcoin miners in the
last 24 hours were paid over 50 million
dollars worth of bitcoin to continue to
secure the network yeah they're gonna do
that as long as they can make money
mining bitcoin which means there has to
be more fools that are willing to buy it
but you're buying in to that hysteria
that more people will keep on buying it
it's a constant pump you got to keep
getting more and more money into into it
more people have to come in uh to
maintain the whole thing because they
want to ask you something
even if bitcoin's price this is
important even if bitcoin's price
dropped 99
the 900 bitcoin that will be mined today
will still be mined if bitcoin's price
drops 99. if if bitcoin's price drops 99
percent no one's gonna want to buy it
it's not going to drop
maybe you guys but the vast majority of
people will
will be out of bitcoin for good but let
me i want to ask you one more thing
because i don't this doesn't make any
sense you keep talking about
the digital economy the digital economy
i mean what what do you mean digital
economy i mean just because there's like
a metaverse and and no no not a
metaverse no no we're not talking about
metaverse i'm talking about the fact
that right now if you think of the
businesses that you own in your equity
portfolio how many of them have
factories how many of them have
large transportation uh fleets how many
of them actually produce physical goods
etc a lot of them okay
but well of course that's why you
haven't outperformed me but if you think
about the digital economy right is in
the digital world there are now these
businesses that are being created now
there are incumbent type digital
business so think of facebook for
example they still have physical
employees they have physical offices but
that's not where the value of that
business is derived the value of that
business is derived from what happens in
the digital world not the physical world
well no
facebook derives its value from
advertising revenue and people are
advertising real things in the physical
world that people not always people need
and not buy not always well what are
they and so take let's say for example a
media company right many of the media
companies are advertising to have
digital subscribers for their digital
content on top of that right but the the
people who are creating that content
they need to eat they need to live
somewhere they buy products i mean our
trade deficits are at all time record
highs because we're buying more actual
stuff of course
digital
digital food and live in a digital house
and drive digital cars i mean people use
wait one second wait one second hold on
i'm gonna let peter uh chime in here in
a second but
in you're a little bit older than me not
much but a little bit uh when you first
started to drive you had to do what you
would go
buy a car you'd go to the gas station
you would buy a map a physical map
look where you were going on a long road
trip and you would start to drive
and you normally would have to have a
physical either eight track or a cd rom
or whatever in order to listen to music
etc
now if you just think about getting in a
car and going on a long road you don't
buy the physical map anymore it's been
digitized you now use the digital
version of that asset you don't buy the
8-track or the cd-rom or the cassette
tape player instead what you buy is you
have digital music that you probably are
paying a subscription you don't even
actually own the song itself that's been
digitized and so there are some things
like a car that will never be digital
you will never be able to take the car
put it in some digital world and then
you and i can like fly down the highway
digitally right so yes there are still
things that will exist in the analog
world but the trend is that everything
in your life that can be digitized will
be digitized and i would even argue that
the taxi
has been digitized because now what has
occurred is the
largest taxi company in the world owns
no cars the largest hotel chain in the
world owns no hotels they have all
become asset light digital first
businesses now because the the important
part you mentioned the cars are still
there they're still on the road agreed
and even if the drivers one day go away
and they're self you know autonomous
vehicles we're going to digitize the
drivers no they're not there the cars
are still there but you know what money
is like the car money ain't going to be
digitized you're not going to take real
money and just represent it digitally
well that's what is bitcoin or not
nobody's already been represented
digitally no no no that's fiat you can
you can take fiat currency and represent
it digitally i'm not talking about fiat
i'm talking about real money which is a
commodity is going to be a real thing
but in the history of money
you're hoping that bitcoin can replace
fiat paper currencies
no no no we're not actually but anyway
just like history of money you're
obviously a gold guy you studied the
history of money all the different forms
of money during the evolution of money
did they all have uses outside of being
money did you lie stones and marbles
when they were used what were their use
cases
what what was the use case for what like
rye stones and marbles the history of
money forms of money things that became
marble when was what you mean you talked
about marbles
little marbles that kids play with yeah
they well then that's what they did they
played with them no no no history toys
historically they didn't become nothing
became money shells became money unless
yeah but people you know what they did
with the shelves they adorn themselves
with them like cigarettes were money
right in prisons the gis used them
because because you could smoke them the
reason that cigarettes were valuable as
money was because someone could win my
bitcoin if i can wear my bitcoin does it
have value you can't wear your big well
if i can wear a representation no well
that's no but the point i'm doing there
is
is that you what you seem to be missing
here is that we aren't even against gold
in this room you know there's gold in
bitcoin we're not against it we
understand that people use it people
like yourself want to store it you seem
to be missing the point that other
people just don't care about gold
they've found a new form of money and
they're going to because they think they
did they they found fool's gold
bear with it people enough people 150
million people worldwide have decided
this is the form of money that they want
and yeah
bear with me they like the trade-offs
they don't care that isn't used
industrious but they like the trade-offs
that they can store it on their phone or
their wallet send anywhere in the world
instantly so they've made that choice
that they think that's better money hold
on peter peter sorry
why can't you accept that other people
have decided this is the form of money
they want they haven't decided it's the
form of money they decided this is what
they're going to buy to get rich no no
people think people expect the price of
bitcoin to go way up if they didn't do
that right let's assume people assumed
that the current price of bitcoin
whatever it is fifty six thousand fifty
seven thousand whatever that's a long
way from when you heard about it let's
say that everybody accepted that this
was it this was as high as it was going
to go right 57 000 this is the price how
many people would still be buying it
right now if they thought this was the
peak hey you know i'm happy
to have i want bitcoin as my money i
want to use it but it's 57 000. it's not
going up right this is where it is do
you think you would still have all these
people what is it
would it would it
would it be because then it's still not
stable because then it's subject to the
the debate okay it's gonna go up with
inflation okay it's gonna go up i'll
tell you five percent a year six percent
a year whatever i'll give you six
million people straight away i have it
the entire population of el salvador
because they wouldn't need to be
dollarized anymore